AI is being used to help decide whether or not you get that job interview,
how much you pay for your car insurance,
how good your credit score is,
and even what rating you get in your annual performance review.
But these decisions are all being filtered through its assumptions
about our identity, our race, our gender, our age.
How is that happening?
Now, imagine an AI is helping a hiring manager
find the next tech leader in the company.
So far, the manager has been hiring mostly men,
so the AI learns men are more likely to be programmers than women.
And it's very shortly from there to men make better programmers than women.
We have reinforced our own bias into the AI,
and now it's screening out female candidates.
Hang on, if a human hiring manager did that, we'd be outraged.
We wouldn't allow it.
This kind of gender discrimination is not OK.
And yet, somehow, AI has become above the law
because the machine made the decision.
That's not it.
We are also reinforcing our bias in how we interact with AI.
How often do you use a voice assistant like Siri, Alexa or even Cortana?
They all have two things in common.
One, they can never get my name right.
And second, they are all female.
They're designed to be your obedient servants,
turning your lights on and off, ordering your shopping.
You get male AIs too, but they tend to be more high-powered,
like IBM Watson making business decisions,
Salesforce Science Team or Ross, the robot lawyer.
So, poor robots, even they suffer from sexism in the workplace.
Think about how these two things combine
and affect a kid growing up in today's world around AI.
So, they're doing some research for a school project,
and they Google images of CEO.
The algorithm shows them results of mostly men.
And now, they Google personal assistant.
As you can guess, it shows them mostly females.
And then, they want to put on some music and maybe order some food.
And now, they're barking orders at a female voice,
an obedient female voice assistant.
Some of our brightest minds are creating this technology today,
technology that they could have created in any way they wanted.
And yet, they've chosen to create it in the style of 1950s Mad Men Secretary.
Yay!
But okay, don't worry.
This is not going to end with me telling you
that we're all heading towards sexist racist machines running the world.
The good news about AI is that it is entirely within our control.
We get to teach the right values, the right ethics to AI.
So, there are three things we can do.
One, we can be aware of our own biases
and the bias in machines around us.
Two, we can make sure there are diverse teams building this technology.
And three, we have to give it diverse experiences to learn from.
I can talk about the first two from personal experience.
When you work in technology and you don't look like a Mark Zuckerberg or Elon Musk,
your life is a little bit difficult, your ability gets questioned.
Here's just one example.
Like most developers, I often join online tech forums
and share my knowledge to help others.
And I found when I log on as myself with my own photo, my own name,
I tend to get questions or comments like this.
What makes you think you're qualified to talk about AI?
What makes you think you know about machine learning?
So, as you do, I made a new profile.
And this time, instead of my own picture,
I chose a cat with a jetpack on it.
And I chose a name that did not reveal my gender.
You can probably guess where this is going, right?
So, this time, I didn't get any of those patronizing comments about my ability,
and I was able to actually get some work done.
And it sucks, guys.
I've been building robots since I was 15,
I have a few degrees in computer science,
and yet, I had to hide my gender in order for my work to be taken seriously.
So, what's going on here?
Are men just better at technology than women?
Another study found that when women coders on one platform
hid their gender, like myself,
their code was accepted 4% more than men.
So, this is not about the talent.
This is about an elitism in AI
that says a programmer needs to look like a certain person.